the Democracy Busters that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right heads we win tails you lose
how our vaunted Defenders of democracy
seem to be framing the 2024 election
cycle
in other words if Biden wins all will be
well again in the world democracy lives
to see another day
but if someone like Trump ends up
winning meaning they win enough states
to push them over 270 electoral votes it
means the whole system implodes
warning blow heart alert
the consequences of losing uh any
candidate losing to Donald Trump and
then becoming the next president
catastrophic for American democracy if
these people were to gain power again
then I I really do think for the only
the second time in American history
we would put our Collective fate at risk
the dangers associated with another
Trump presidency like say the
existential threat to our democracy this
is a close race and I think this is the
danger for those of us that actually
believe in democracy and want to
preserve it
oh I get it
democracy only works going forward if
they can get enough mail-in ballots
returned and early votes cast to swamp
the populist giving the win to the
octogenarian who cannot find his way off
the stage
that is a very convenient way of
approaching things is it not
now they're obviously freaking out and
they're resorting to strained legal
arguments even their Fringe theories
that turn the Constitution into a piece
of silly putty that you can stretch into
anything you want
so now never Trump Scholars turn
political hacks are trying to argue that
Trump
should be barred
constitutionally barred from running for
office now this is patently absurd
especially coming from judges who once
called themselves originalists like our
old friend Mike ludig now as you listen
to this I want you to remember that they
have strenuously argued that Trump's
team was guilty of wildly distorting the
Constitution regarding challenges to the
state vote counts uh and the
establishing of alternate slate of
electors watch
the people who wrote the 14th Amendment
were not fools they realized that if
those people who try to over turn the
country who try to get rid of our
peaceful transitions of Power are again
put in power that would be the end of
the nation the end of democracy all
officials federal and state who have a
responsibility uh to put on the ballot
candidates for the presidency of the
United States for instance
they himself or herself are obligated
under the Constitution
to determine whether
Donald Trump qualifies to be put on the
ballot
what try to follow that now again they
accused Trump of pulling apart the
Constitution after the election and you
can argue about what Trump did but what
are they doing
and to think by the way he was once
considered Supreme Court material during
the Bush Administration what a total
disgrace and it pains me to say that
they're terrified that the people are
going to reject both Biden and them and
their illogical views
and of course you can always count on
Academia to give birth to the most
radical of proposals and again from the
so-called Protectors of our cherished
democracy UPenn psychologist Adam Grant
wants to abolish elections altogether
writing the ancient Greeks invented
democracy and in Athens many government
officials were selected through
sortition a random Lottery from a pool
of candidates in the United States we
already use a version of a lottery to
select jurors what if we did the same
with Mayors Governors legislators
justices
and even presidents okay well before you
just write this off completely and I did
get a good chuckle out of it remember
remember this the gender fluidity
movement the trans movement CRT those
Fringe theories were also born in the
universities as well
so once again
the Democrats finger of accusation is
always pointed back at them
they accuse Trump and if it wasn't Trump
it'd be someone else of undermining
democracy committing felonies because
they he challenged the election results
yet we've already documented this you
know they've challenged repeatedly
challenged election results and when
they do it
uh they say it's just part of the
democratic process
so the bottom line is Democrats just
simply don't much like or trust you the
voters
they think you're stupid but you're not
you see what works and what doesn't work
what Prosperity is and what it's not
you know when a border is secure and
when it's open
and you know that election should be
determined by the voters
certainly not controlled by big donors
or big Tech or bitter academics
desperate for attention
that's democracy and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else